venture capital is it good or is it bad
i'm john coogan and today we are finally
going to get to the bottom of this
pressing question
now obviously there's no definitive
answer but
charles duhigg's latest article in the
new yorker criticizes the vc industry
pretty heavily so i thought it would be
good to examine some of what i think
duhigg gets right
as well as some of the conclusions that
i think are a bit more of a stretch
full disclosure i generally like both
venture capital and the new yorker
i've raised over 10 rounds of vc funding
in my career i've also been a reader of
the new yorker for over 10 years
so i didn't immediately write off either
side of the debate and honestly
i just think it's kind of fun to see
these two clashing
the core thesis of du higgs piece is
that venture capitalists encourage
recklessness
by providing early stage companies with
overly large funding rounds
now this idea is nothing new in fact
eric paley a partner at founder
collective
penned a piece in techcrunch four years
ago warning founders about the risks of
raising too much money
but while paley focuses on the
individual risks to founders
duhigg instead focuses on the systemic
risks to the american capitalist system
his worry is that the current state of
venture capital is actually
limiting innovation by pouring too much
money into losing companies
and making it impossible for the
stronger company to win
this is an interesting point to debate
it's true that venture capital has grown
significantly over the past decade
and it's also true that rounds of over a
hundred million dollars or
mega deals have grown even faster there
have also been
a bunch of high profile startup failures
like theranos and juicero
so it's worth investigating if there is
a causal relationship between venture
capital and failure
duhigg focuses on wework as his
cornerstone example of what can happen
when a startup gets
too much funding and flies off the rails
wework is a great case study because
unlike theranos who raised money from
outside of silicon valley
wework was actually backed by
traditional venture capitalists and
unlike jucero
wework raised over 10 billion dollars
and has now been in business for over 10
years
jucera raised less than one percent of
that before flaming out in just a few
years
and perhaps most importantly wework is a
salacious story
the founder adam newman is clearly a
crazy character
so much so that hollywood is already
planning to make a movie about the
wework saga
and people love stories about
high-flying failures just look at the
slide bean youtube channel and you can
tell that demand for stories about
business disasters far
outpaces any other type of content i'll
be honest
i love reading these types of accounts
and even though i already knew most of
the details
i still enjoyed the way duhigg tells the
story most
impressively he actually managed to get
one of the wework board members to speak
on the record about the company this is
extremely rare
since confidentiality agreements are
commonplace and discussing company drama
with the press
usually only hurts your company as a
board member you have a fiduciary duty
to the shareholders of the company
so if you say something negative to a
reporter and that winds up hurting your
company
you could actually be sued but the fact
that we work with such a disaster
doesn't really indict the entire tech
industry in my mind wework was founded
in 2010
the same year that pinterest datadog and
sumo logic were all founded
these three companies might not have
been as high profile as we work
but all three were heavily vc-backed
raised over 100 million dollars in
funding and are now publicly traded
companies
they're all doing fine and this
underscores one of the main criticisms
vcs always get
the industry is designed to place big
bets on lots of companies knowing full
well that many will fail
no one has a crystal ball to see exactly
what will work so the vc industry tests
many ideas in parallel
duhigg doesn't explicitly take umbrage
with the idea of diversified early stage
investing as a strategy
he instead argues that vcs should be
more engaged in the everyday management
of the company
to illustrate this point he cites the
role tom perkins played in genentech's
growth back in the 1970s
perkins not only took a board seat but
actually spent one afternoon per week
in the startup's offices helping the
company directly
this is a great story and tom perkins is
obviously a legendary vc
but it glosses over some important facts
about what his firm
kleiner perkins was actually doing in
the 1970s
the first fund posted amazing returns of
over 40 percent per year but not every
investment was a success
one of the first companies they backed
was called advanced recreation equipment
and they manufactured a very silly
looking snowmobile motorcycle
the device was sold in the back of
magazines under the brand name
snow job terrible i know and the company
got crushed when the oil embargo hit and
gasoline prices spiked
if venture capital had been under the
microscope back in the 70s
you could totally imagine a big article
about how the snow job was nothing new
and a huge waste of money that could
have gone to more promising businesses
but today we don't remember tom perkins
for the snow job
we just remembered genentech this is the
survivorship bias in action
and it distorts the way we see the world
it's easy to look back and say
today's vc should be like tom perkins
but maybe you don't get
genentech's synthetic insulin without
trying out the snow jobs
snowmobile motorcycle first shifting
back to the new yorker piece
duhigg hits pretty hard on the role that
late-stage venture capital plays
in distorting markets he continually
cites softbank as a major culprit
and he's right to do so softbank has had
some real misses lately
but while most people think of them as a
venture capital firm there's actually
some debate about where the lines
should be drawn traditionally i think of
venture capitalists as people who write
checks between 1
and 100 million dollars anyone who
writes a check smaller than a million
dollars
is generally called an angel investor
and historically
investments larger than 100 million
dollars have come from private equity
funds
not vc firms to be fair to do higg the
vc industry is somewhat responsible for
allowing these definitions to become
muddled
plenty of small angel investors brand
themselves as vcs
and lots of later stage growth equity
firms have started to style themselves
as vcs to garner the higher prestige
associated with the earlier stage
industry
additionally some vc firms go as far as
to call anyone who works for them a
partner
further adding to the confusion about
who is and who isn't an actual venture
capitalist
in my view we need to separate these
things out a tiny angel investor's role
is radically different from a
professional firm that buys nearly half
of a company for billions of dollars
the scrutiny critiques and regulations
that we as a society apply to these
disparate groups
should all take into account the nuances
involved with each of these investment
phases
and that leads me to my last point the
demonization of venture capitalists
i actually don't think that the article
is too hard on vcs generally
but there is one quote that is utterly
hilarious
duhigg quotes the founder of a wework
competitor who says
vcs seem like these quiet boring guys
who are good at math
encourage you to dream big and have
private planes you know who else is
quiet good at math and has private
planes drug cartels
this is a pretty ridiculous comparison
when i first read quiet
good at math private plane i honestly
thought that the guy was about to
compare all vcs to jeffrey epstein
it's just such a blatant attempt to
trash the entire industry why not just
lean in all the way
are some vcs terrible absolutely are
some vcs great
also yes at one point duhigg calls out
founder's fund for being overly
founder-friendly
but founder's fund never invested in any
of the startup failures cited in the
piece
so it's odd why they are being included
maybe the founder friendly model works
for them
but not for other firms at the end of
the day
duhigg's article is still a fun read and
i think that's enough to merit
publishing
does it miss some of the nuances of
venture capital sure but
an industry outsider will never be able
to capture everything in an 8 000 word
article
and hey if it gives someone ammunition
to put the brakes on the next wework
before it gets too big
that's probably a good thing let's just
make sure not to kill off the next
genentech because we're worried that it
might be a snow job
but what do you think has the vc
industry gone completely off the rails
or do you think the venture model still
makes sense leave me a comment below
and if you enjoyed this video please
consider subscribing to the channel
thanks for watching